so the first trailer is out for the tomb
raider movie starring Alicia vikander
and I had a few thoughts that I wanted
to put out there I didn't think it was
gonna have any I hadn't planned to do a
video when the trailer came out but when
I did actually see the thing I'm like I
think I gotta talk this one out a little
bit so first of all for context I don't
have a particularly heavy investment in
the Tomb Raider games I played them yeah
I've played them a little bit off and on
across the series never been a huge fan
but I've always kind of followed it to a
certain extent I mean I'm like that with
gaming in general there's lots of sort
of franchises and stuff that I follow
what's going on
in them because I find that stuff
interesting even though I don't play a
lot of games anymore but I do have a
very strong soft spot for the previous
Lara Croft film starring Angelina Jolie
and I say that knowing they're not
actually all that good but I enjoy them
I actually own both of them and I kind
of set them aside along with the first
Mortal Kombat film in that look I know
it's not great but as far as video game
movies go this is pretty decent and my
feeling about those previous films is
that they in terms of the action the
styling they're very much of the era
they were made and late 90s early 2000s
excepting the matrix wasn't actually a
great period for action movies in a lot
of ways once the matrix hit things got
better again but these ones that you can
still sort of feel the 90s miss them
even though they are actually early
2000s movies but it's buoyed by Angelina
Jolie's performance because I think
she's magnetic and fun and just a
wonderful to watch in the part so my
thoughts on this trailer kept going back
and forth because I'd seen the images
early on you know sort of the the
initial images of her with a bow looking
all dirty I saw that one
oh okay they're going new Lara Croft
they're going to reboot version this is
very obviously survivalist Lara Croft as
opposed to high-flying
Lara Croft but then I'm watching the
trailer and it's her like doing this
little puzzle box and you know gearing
up for this adventure and being told by
a message from her father that the world
may hang in the balance I'm like oh okay
are they just borrowing the aesthetic
from the newer grittier thing but
they're keeping the the more high
concept adventure elements from the from
the previous movies and the early games
and then the ship gets wrecked and she
just washes up and she's held by a guy
at gunpoint and it's very much in
survivalist mode again and I just I I
was getting total whiplash throughout
the the trailer and I'm like okay wait a
minute wait a minute are we doing the
survivalist thing or are we doing the
high action adventure thing and as I say
that I do understand that in terms of
the movie itself it is not impossible
for it to find a way to balance both of
those I do think it might have been a
bad idea to try and sell both those
angles in the same two minute trailer
because Condesa of that time frame you
don't get a smooth transition from one
mood to the other I just kind of like I
said it whips you back and forth and the
two weren't quite gelling for me and if
they have actually made a movie that
blends both aspects I hope it works
certainly but that I think can make it
tougher to sell because if yeah I
dispose and I mean what were the other
options if they weren't gonna try and
cram both moves into this one trailer
well you go all one or go all the other
you go all the high adventure mode and
then you know people who are into the
newer reboot one are like oh you just
did the old version you go all
survivalists old-school fans might not
come in and especially if you do have
both aspects in the movie selling it
only on one of them can make people feel
cheated when they actually get there and
realize that that isn't completely what
the movie is although if you do it
correctly whatever the extra element is
could be a nice surprise so I don't envy
the marketers trying to sell this movie
but there's just something that isn't
gelling for me as we're jumping between
you know her you know being in a very
dire situation like
this glyph and hitting this this tree on
the way down and the impact it hits hard
and feels like it hurts like odd you
know that doesn't feel like fun action
damage that felt like a hard impactful
hit and then at the end show her with
the guns that Lara that the angelina
jolie version was known for and being oh
I'll take two and like that those are
mixing for me and I don't know if I'm
alone in this opinion I haven't bothered
to check what reactions to this trailer
like before I record this cuz I want my
opinion to be my own opinion and not a
response to what everyone else is saying
so I might be the only one with this
issue I fully accept that that is a
distinct possibility but yeah there's
something about trying to marry the dark
gritty and the fun action elements of
this franchise that at least as far as
the trailer is presenting it the two
aren't blending well now I I will keep
an eye out for a next trailer I've said
in the past that when when I see a
trailer that sells me on a movie I'm
like I'm definitely gonna see that I
basically stop watching future trailers
because I don't want to get spoiled this
one I'm really on the fence about so I
will keep an eye out for future trailers
and see if they can sort of give me a
better sense of what the final product
is going to be I just worry that this
sort of schizophrenic nature of these
elements is just gonna just turn some
people off and not turn them off as like
I'm not gonna go see that but just fail
to sell it hard enough that people will
go out of their way it's more of a oh
maybe if I'm not doing anything that
weekend and that kind of response is
more or less where something like prince
of persia landed and that doesn't get
your franchise launched and I've said in
the past that I don't think video game
movies are going to work it's certainly
not as they've been trying them and not
with most of the properties they've been
trying to do them with tomb Raider's one
of the few that could work because the
nature and the narrative of the games is
episodic enough that you could do a
completely contained satisfying
adventure in one film and I mean you
just do female Indiana Jones it were
but at the same time it's like what are
they gonna be able to do to sell it as
more than that I don't know so I'll keep
an eye on it we'll see but this trailer
oh and to be clear Alicia vikander the
the tone issues aside seems to be
playing the part fine I think especially
if they're going at least visually for
the newer reboot Lara Croft she's a good
match for that so no knock on her or any
of the rest of the cast it's just the
tone of the thing overall is just it
didn't I yeah I'm not biting right now
so we'll see what happens what were your
thoughts on this trailer whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast feed available
on iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast which
will be on the fire and water Network
starting in October so give a listen to
that as well and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]